we tested that the database was created
successfully but now we should test that
reading from in writing to the sunshine
database works as expected I'll show you
how we insert a row of data into the
database and then query the database to
read it back out first we get a
reference to the database from our
SQLite open helper which is an instance
of an SQLite database object we use this
in test create DB since we're riding to
the database as well as reading we're
going to get a writable database if we
were only reading then we should use a
readable database to represent the row
of data we want to insert into the
database we use a content values object
we create one of these in the create
North Pole location values utility
function content values contain a set of
key value pairs you put a key string
associated with the value into the
content value set the key strings
contain the names of columns in your
database the value can contain many
different data types content values are
used to write to databases in android
once we've created our content values we
call database insert with the table name
and content values to actually create
the new row of data the return value
from our insertion is a long that
contains the new row ID from the
underscore ID column if there's an error
inserting the return value is negative 1
now that we have a row ID we can query
the database for that row there are
several query methods that take in
different numbers of parameters a query
method is just a helper function to make
it easier to construct and execute a
select statement let's show how the
query function constructs a statement
here's what the base SQLite database
query function looks like the most basic
query we can make with this only has a
table name and it returns all columns in
all records the rest of the parameters
would modify and filter the output of
this query adding a projection an array
of columns we wish to return changes
what we are selecting in the Select
statement below the selection parameter
filters the results one can optionally
also use the selection arguments to
replace any question marks in the query
Android creates these as bound
parameters in a low level interface
sqlite which means we don't have to
worry about things like escaping the
strings to keep the query valid we can
also change the selection arguments
after our query has been made this way
the last parameter as you would expect
affects the order by Clause of our query
causing it to sort our result in
descending order by date the query
functions all return a database cursor a
cursor object is a control structure
that enables traversal over the rows and
columns of our query result set
typically we'll start traversing result
set by calling cursor dot move to first
which will return false if there were no
rows in the result which means nothing
matched the query parameters we can then
call move to next iterate through each
row once the cursor points to a valid
row one can call get column index to
return the index of each database column
within the result set you can save these
values and use them for every row in the
result and then you can call getter
methods that retrieve the values from
that row based upon column index
everything we've covered so far is how
we read and write from the database in
our app in tests and in our app code for
our unit tests though we add a step to
validate the values from the cursor with
the ones we originally created the
content values object with by using
assert statements and when we're
finished we should close our cursor and
database to release the system resources
as soon as possible